hello everyone my name is sy venom and
I'm with the IBM cloud team today we're
gonna be talking about terraform
terraform is an open-source tool
originally developed by Hoshi Corp but
it enables you to automate and manage
your infrastructure and platform and
services as well it does all of this
using a declarative language and that's
the first thing we're going to focus on
when we go through our example to go
through terraform so I generally like to
start with an example here so say you're
driving in your car trying to get from
point A to point B generally you would
follow a set of instructions right so
from point A to point B they have to
take a left turn get on the highway take
this exit you end up at your destination
now that's kind of an imperative
approach to automation the way terraform
does it imagine you call the taxi or a
rideshare service and told them exactly
where you wanted to go
point B the car or the driver then takes
care of the rest you don't have to worry
about every step of the way to get there
and that's the approach terraform takes
that's why it's so effective at managing
your infrastructure today we'll start
with an example say you've got three
different resources that you're trying
to spin up as part of your
infrastructure
we'll say you've got a VM will also say
you've got a kubernetes cluster and say
that they're networked together using a
VP C or virtual private cloud so current
state nothings their desired state is
this set of infrastructure so in
terraform there's going to be three
major phases and we'll go step by step
the first phase you actually have to
create the the terraform file so we'll
start with that where you actually write
or code up that terraform file now in
this terraform file we're going to have
three major resources right so we'll
start with the VM and a set of arguments
to support that things like the name and
networking data center that kind of
thing we'll have the kubernetes cluster
set of arguments for that and then
finally we've also got the VP see it's
probably going to refer to some of the
network settings of the VM and the coup
Burnett
cluster but it's going to network those
together and so it has arguments to
support that so that's your coding phase
say you've got a terraform file TF file
with these things defined next up we've
got the plan phase now this is an actual
terraform command so in the TF CLI or
command-line interface you can run
terraform plan and what it's going to do
is it's going to compare the desired
state to what actually exists so you
know day 0 it'll notice that you have
none of these resources so it'll say hey
you have to create all of them so create
the VM create the cluster as well as
create the VPC so it has a plan and it
tells you the user this is what it's
going to do next if everything looks
good you'll do the apply phase this is
another terraform CLI command and then
they apply phase you can actually take
those resources and spin them up so
that's exactly what's going to happen
terraform is going to work against the
cloud providers using real ap is your
API token to spin up these
infrastructure resources and it's going
to output some interesting or
auto-generated variables along the way
so for example maybe the kubernetes
dashboard URL or maybe even a URL to
access your application but regardless
it's going to output a number of these
output variables so that's generally how
that's generally how the terraform
workflow goes to get you from point A to
point B in a situation where you had
nothing and now you have something so
that's what I wanted to start with next
I want to go into the fact that
terraform has a strong open community
and it's pluggable by design so by
pluggable essentially what I mean here
is the fact that it's made up of modules
and resources where put in input
variables and output comes out as well
as the communities out there and cloud
providers are out there building and
supporting things called cloud providers
or providers in the terraform world to
enable you to connect up to any cloud
and automate infrastructure there
so in this process we actually made
something called a terraform module so
terraform module is a way of grouping
together some terraform automation so
we've got a terraform module here it
actually takes a set of input and also
creates some output and as part of every
module well you can define this but in
generally when you're working with cloud
providers and using terraform you'll
also define what's called a provider now
a provider can be a number of things but
in our case we were using it as a cloud
provider to connect up to a given cloud
so that's the first thing that a
provider can do is connect you up to I
as providers IBM cloud or AWS or Azure
enables you to connect up to some
infrastructure provider spin up things
like VMs or that kind of thing maybe
bare-metal you can also use a provider
in the terraform sense to spin up you
know platforms as well so it enables you
to manage for example Cloud Foundry
running in the cloud
finally you can even manage SAS
offerings things like CloudFlare or
other software services can actually be
managed by terraform so although
terraform is considered to be an
infrastructure automation tool it's
expanded its role to support other types
of providers as well so essentially
we've got our flow here our module
inputs and outputs and so we've got a
kind of pipeline to be able to spin up
resources the last advantage I want to
mention here would terraform is the fact
that it enables you to essentially have
the best practices for DevOps
so we'll say DevOps first now let's take
an example for this now in our example
here we did add a day one kind of
deployment nothing to something but
let's say we're going back and iterating
on this so we've got our VP see we've
got our VM as well as kubernetes now
let's say we're iterating on this and we
want to create something new on top of
this infrastructure
let's say we want a load balancer so
that's our desired State so we'll do our
three phases start with the code phase
so we'll say here that we want a load
balancer and we'll have set of arguments
to support that when we get to the plan
phase terraform is going to realize hey
we actually already have the vm
kubernetes and VPC since it checks the
current state of the world and realizes
all we need is that new load balancer so
I'll say hey let's just add the load
balancer this time around and as a user
you'll confirm that make sure it looks
good go to the apply phase go ahead and
apply it maybe some more config
variables will come out for this new
capability that you added so essentially
with terraform you have a devops first
approach one of the key advantages to
this enables you to avoid potential
config drift that's when the
configuration that defines your
infrastructure actually doesn't match
what's actually there so as long as all
changes to your infrastructure go
through the terraform file the terraform
pipeline you can essentially eliminate
the risk of configuration drift in
addition since we've set up a module
where we can take input variables and
have a final state what we can
essentially do is recreate this maybe
switch up the environment variables a
bit and then create and a whole nother
environment so it looks just like this
but this time we can make one for test
and maybe this one was dead and we can
do that again
for maybe prod it's another advantage of
taking a terraform approach to
infrastructure automation enables you to
put DevOps first thanks for joining us
for this quick overview of terraform if
you enjoyed this video be sure to check
out our other video on infrastructure as
code as always if you liked this video
or have any comments be sure to drop a
like or a comment below stay tuned and
subscribe for more videos like this in
the future thank you